finally because this past year we've
been in each other's business
with so much anxiety we're gonna have to
learn to loosen that monkey tight grip
let's serve up some news sunny side up
first story comes to us from zambia
which is in southern africa
fox news reports a woman sued her
boyfriend
for taking too long to propose to her
all right listen up
if you ever want to do this somebody
beat you to it gertrude who's 26 went to
court to call out
herbert who's 28 for wasting her darn
time for the last eight years
they already have a kid together her
family already paid a dowry which is
part of the culture there
but there's herbert twiddle his thumbs
he's not asking her he's not doing it
and a judge when she took him to court
the judge said nothing they could do
the court can't do anything to force him
to get married oh good
but it does make you wonder like have
you ever been in that position where
it's like
tick-tock let's do this uh if not
approach the bench i don't know what
would you guys do in this situation
well wait a second 26. yeah
like i mean i had a lot of boyfriends by
the time i was 12.
god not me you know it's not that
that's you still have a lot of time hon
like you're okay
you're gonna be okay guys this next
story really revs my motors
forbes reports that you can now totally
obliterate a car
with a battle tank to get out your
demons in 2020
it's called the rage yard experience
offered by a scrap car company in the uk
and they let you drive a 61-ton
chieftain battle tank
straight into a car to let out your fury
i know you love this did rage making
what about this
andrew does anybody wanna just like
random
[Applause]
20 20.
our next story this really spoke to me
as the animal lover i am it turns out
that a bunch of endangered species
are making a comeback and the good news
network
has a list of animals who are almost
extinct but are absolutely now
thriving like the four-eyed turtles now
they actually don't wear glasses because
they would slide right off
they don't have ears the world wildlife
fund
says that tigers are also making a big
comeback and
that's in south asia russia china
fantastic work tigers
yeah because you always want to be on
the good side of a tiger i know because
i greet one every morning
when i bring out the hair brush to my
daughter i almost lose my face and hand
in more animal news it's been reported
that mount rainier
has had its first wolverine sighting in
over a hundred years
no not that wolverine i know but
a mama wolverine and her two baby
wolverines were spotted prowling the
park
and i'll tell ya a family of wolverines
i get you
i see you i avatar tale with you because
i'm going to show you a picture that i
show to people when i'm trying to
describe the mother i am
with my children i'm a doberman i'm
protective you feel me
so on that note let's see what rebel
related news made the papers today
all right cnn they ran this piece and i
want to share it with you
they're saying that now is the perfect
time
to give up perfectionist parenting i
love that they stopped telling you a
24-hour news cycle and actually got
really philosophical
because this is the subject we're all
struggling so i say
thank you cnn finally
because this past year we've been in
each other's business with so much
anxiety we're gonna have to learn to
loosen that monkey tight grip
that's cutting off my circulation and
learn to let it go
[Music]